foreign
everybody we're doing something a little
bit different today as we end the year
2022 I have to say on a personal note
this was by far the best year of my life
uh I got two kids how about that uh
Justin and Luke downstairs right now
most likely pooping sleeping spitting up
possibly rolling around it's been an
incredible year obviously this was the
year that Florida really got in my pores
technically we got here on December 17
2021 so this was really our first full
year in Florida and just the the taste
that sweet beautiful dewy Taste of
Freedom that is in the air here at all
times and and leaving California where
our in essence Was An Enemy of the State
to be in a place where my values and the
things that I care about and that I talk
to you guys about and communicate with
you about all the time are are aligned
and flourishing it was just just an
extraordinary year this was by far also
the biggest year for the show we
absolutely crushed it across platforms
YouTube basically every month was our
best month ever we launched on Rumble
and that has absolutely exploded and as
I'll get into it a little bit obviously
with the merger that Rumble did with
locals which is the company I created
like there was just so much good energy
around building the new rails of the
internet and some of that's connected to
what elon's doing with Twitter and it
was really just a wonderful year so we
thought we'd do something a little bit
different today because I didn't want to
just smash you guys over the head with
the Daily Show during Christmas week
because I want everybody to kind of
enjoy themselves and relax and eat and
be with family and everything else so
we're doing two separate videos this
week one of them will be our 15 craziest
political moments and this one today is
just one highlight per month uh that was
sort of a personal and professional and
political personal professional and
political the three p's uh that happened
this year and we're going to start in
January of 2022 this was my first show
just a snippet of my first show from the
free state of Florida
[Music]
the goods
if all of our hard work has paid off if
all of the computer machines and the
electronic wires and all of the weirdo
gadgets that these two fine gentlemen
who are in this room with me right now
have been fiddling with all day if all
of that has come together if that red
light that I'm staring into is working
then this is officially the first Reuben
report
from my new house in Florida there is an
awful lot to talk about this is a rare
nighttime show for us but we got the
keys at about noon today it was a Mad
Dash to get in here it has taken about
two and a half almost three weeks extra
to actually get in here I thought we
were going to get to Florida well I know
when we got to Florida which was
December 18th I thought maybe we could
close on the house right before
Christmas then I thought it could be
right after Christmas then it looked
like it was going to be right after New
Year that some other stuff happened then
oh hell broke loose whole bunch of
things related to covet and delays and
Banks and loans and all these different
people pushing paper across desks but we
made it we are in we've been busting our
butts all day long and this is my first
show from our temporary
Florida home studio so that was our
first show in this house from our
temporary Florida Studio which is still
somewhat temporary we're still in the
same Studio we're figuring out some
things that we can do in the coming year
uh to build a a separate operation and a
bigger situation I'll have more on that
as the year unfolds of course we also
did then open up the local Studios which
I'm going to be spending a lot more time
in in the year going forward and getting
back to some live in-person interviews
and a bunch more uh but that was January
we got here we moved the whole team here
I moved to in essence two companies here
and a whole bunch of people and we
didn't know what it was going to be like
were we all going to be happy here what
was it going to be like to be amongst
like-minded people instead of the crazy
Communists of California but we got here
we've been flourishing freedom is here
uh this is the center of the center of
the Freedom Movement and the future of
America and I'm thrilled to be here and
that's how we kicked off the year here
in February you may remember this the
letter that Rumble sent to Joe Rogan I
actually wrote this letter myself when
Rumble offered Joe Rogan a hundred
million bucks to leave Spotify and move
over to rumble he did not take the offer
but it was a first Salvo in uh in
showing that Rumble is legit and that we
are going to fight at every possible
level whether it's technologically or
financially or philosophically whatever
it might be and I wrote that it was a
legit offer and I do know that he at
least entertained it to some degree and
that was the beginning
of feeling like momentum was picking up
in the fight for free speech online
which of course as you guys know really
became the theme of the year uh in the
next month March speaking of free speech
well that's when uh Justin Trudeau Evil
Lizard person Justin Trudeau really
cracked down on the Canadian truckers
and their supporters this was a group of
people largely blue-collar workers who
just wanted the country to open up who
just wanted to go to work get their kids
into schools be able to go back to
church and Temple and and live their
lives normally and Trudeau crashed down
on them in a way that I don't think
anyone in Western democracies thought
that our governments could here's a
little something this is Trudeau talking
about the country that he admires most
the level of uh admiration I actually
have for China okay I need you to
explain that one
um because they're you know basic
dictatorship is allowing them uh to
actually turn their economy around on a
diet what about all the other stuff
looks pretty bad it's so beautiful we
may tell you exactly what they are and
that's exactly what he did there I come
in with rainbows and unicorns and
tolerance and love
an
lgbtqi what are all the other letters
lgdp L GT LBT
line and why does he admire China
because China doesn't give a flying F
about their citizens individual rights I
sound like a nice guy but really what I
am is an awful authoritarian of course
that ended up having a nice ending
because Trudeau actually stopped going
after the truckers at least at least
publicly the bank accounts were not
Frozen and the country did start opening
up and changed some of its Draconian
mandates and everything else so there
was a beautiful moment in March and I'm
glad that we were just a little piece of
amplifying that story because that story
was barely covered by the mainstream
media by the corporate press right they
barely barely touched it and when they
bid it was basically to say that hey
these truckers are a bunch of Nazis and
transphobes and everything else but good
people stood up to the machine and
change occurred I actually can't think
of anything that would be more congruent
with the theme of this show in April it
was a big month for me personally and
everything that we were doing around
here don't burn this country
bust out we've got pictures from all
over the place all over the country we
went on a completely sold out tour it
was absolutely wonderful there's me and
Megan Kelly that was in West Nyack that
was in San Jose with Douglas Murray it
was it was just great to get back out on
the road this was also just as the
country was opening up again I think
three days before the tour started they
had the announcement because of a 35
year old female Trump appointed judge
here in Florida and Tampa that the
airlines were not going to have mask
mandates anymore and that was a
beautiful way for me to get you know
basically spend a month uh on airplanes
Non-Stop and there was just such Joy
surrounding uh surrounding the book and
the events and seeing people and people
getting the one second hug and sometimes
a couple would come up and the husband
would forego his one second hug so the
wife could get a two second hug or the
wife would sometimes forego her one
second hug so the husband could get a
two second hug and it was really just
wonderful being out on the road and the
book sold incredibly well should have
been number two on the New York Times
bestseller possibly even number one they
did not put me on at all which to me is
the highest compliment that they could
possibly do and also so indicative of
everything going on with with corporate
media and mainstream media and the whole
thing that if they are going to lie
about sales numbers basic stuff that is
not debatable did you buy that oh we got
money for it we can count that if
they're gonna lie about that do you
think they're going to lie about pretty
much and everything else in May
something really spectacular happened
that I think set the tone for the rest
of the year and a tremendous amount of
what we do on this show Elon Musk went
on the all-in podcast and this is before
he had purchased Twitter this is before
the media started calling him a
right-wing Maniac this is before the
Democrats started you know looking into
his businesses and trying to take him
out and the whole machine Came Crashing
Down on the guy this this is back in May
when he just said hey there's something
going on with Twitter and there's
something going on with the Democrats
um you know the the reality is uh that
Twitter at this point you know has a
very far left bias um and I I would
trust myself as a moderate and you know
neither Republican or nor Democrat
um and in fact uh I have voted voted
overwhelmingly for Democrats uh
historically overwhelmingly like I'm not
sure
I might never have voted for Republican
just to be clear right now now this
election I will
isn't that something else like if you
see where we're at as we wrap up 2022 as
we roll into these last couple of days
where the entire machine is going after
the guy and you literally have
government officials and Senators
looking into his other businesses and
people calling him far right and all
right and a republican a guy who at that
point in his life had never even voted
Republican as far as he could remember
but it's just a beautiful moment because
it was the beginning of the red pilling
process of the richest man on earth and
then he freaking bought Twitter and thus
we got some truth leaked out to us and I
think hopefully the 2023 will be the the
continued year of a little truth being
leaked out every now and again after a
couple years 2020 and 2021 specifically
of the truth being stampled on and and
pushed down and crushed and everything
else in June we ended the don't burn
this country tour and we ended it in
style ladies and gentlemen that's right
Governor DeSantis and I went I believe
it was on June 1st we went to the belly
of the Beast we went to Orlando Florida
that's known as Disney country and we
did the final stop on the book tour I
released this uh my portion of the show
the 45 minutes we released that as my
first ever stand up special don't say
Dave which is free for our local
subscribers so you can buy it one off
999 at reubenreport.locals.com and uh
here's a little bit of me and Governor
DeSantis
well first I just want to say that I
love that you keep calling him Brandon
because
I think it's possible he thinks his name
is Brandon
so that's pretty beautiful also I wasn't
going to do this the end we only have
one more quiet time for one more
question but I wanted to give you a
let's go Brandon t-shirt it seems
that he should put it on right now and
rip it off Hulk Hogan Style
[Applause]
July was a really beautiful month for me
uh first off it was the last month
before I Do by August Off the Grid which
is always nice it feels like things are
tying themselves together but I had a
really nice moment on the other side of
the interview with my friend and mentor
and confidante Jordan Peterson on his
daily wire Plus show where we talked
about building a family and the
importance of having children which I
was on my way to having at that time and
a whole bunch more here's a little clip
from that if you would have said to me
10 years ago that I'd be having this
conversation publicly first off that I'd
be married I wouldn't have believed you
that I'd have be having kids I wouldn't
have believed you that I would be
willing to talk about this or even
someone that even someone that someone
else might look to to help map it for
them I'd say you were completely insane
um this is not really something you know
I'd rather talk about politics I'd
rather talk about the culture wars and
all these other things
because we're trying to sketch out a
pathway I suppose I mean our culture
appears to have decided that
gay marriage is
well I don't know if acceptable is the
right word it's become part of the
structure of marriage itself and so now
the question is okay what does that mean
so we had about a two-hour conversation
on a whole bunch of stuff that I had
never talked about publicly before a
whole bunch of stuff that Jordan had
never really explored in a public manner
before things that he had discussed in
private practice with clients in his
years of uh of therapy but it was it was
important for me and I think really set
me up nicely to have kids and one other
thing that did set me up nicely to have
kids was this moment I had I had Jordan
and my other friend and bonus Mentor
Dennis Prager came over for dinner uh
just two or three days before the end of
July and it was it was beautiful I'm not
posting that to be like oh look at my
friends and look who I have dinner with
I'm posting it because how many people
on Earth how many of you watching this
right now if you were a parent to be at
the at the grand old age of 46 and you
got to sit down and we had we had this
wonderful dinner uh Jordan's wife Tammy
was there as well and David was there
there unfortunately Dennis's wife was
was back in Cali but we had about five
hours to sit there over steak because
Jordan only eat steak and and talk about
what our fears were what our
expectations were if we could get advice
and and everything and like the and the
importance of faith and honesty and
decency and what we're going to struggle
with and the whole thing and it set us
up really really nicely for what was
about to happen earlier than anticipated
in August first I went off the grid and
that is our last show before we went off
the grid that was me drinking a little
of my class Azul Reposado which is my
tequila of choice and people ask me Dave
what do you do with all the cash and
mostly I put it into tequila but then we
thought that Justin was going to be born
his due date was I believe August 24th
turned out to be born on August 5th so
August really changed I thought I was
going to be hanging out in the pool
drinking tequila all day long that
changed real quick I I don't want to
post uh pictures of the kids publicly in
this manner I do Post uh pictures of the
kids with the locals Community uh so I'm
not going to show you a picture of the
kids but they're just Justin is just
absolutely perfect and he's Smiley and
happy and just absolutely wonderful and
and this was a very very different
August Off the Grid usually I'm in the
middle of nowhere just hanging out doing
nothing this one uh yeah a little bit
different and hospital and all that
stuff but uh all good then came back in
September and as you guys know uh
something that I had wanted to do for a
long long long long time I finally got
to sit down with Bill Maher and talk
about life and talk about sex and talk
about drugs and talk about politics and
the whole freaking thing on his Club
random podcast first of all you got to
break up with your boyfriend Donald
Trump who would you say is more
authentic him or Joe Biden him he's more
authentic him or Elizabeth Warren but
authentic does it mean good
authentically a crazy person pretty good
when he was president what what was
pretty good we weren't in a recession
the Border was a little bit better we
didn't have a crazy war in Ukraine like
he hasn't conceded the election for four
years when he was president Hillary
Clinton he's an illegitimate president
yes she did I met him and I I kind of
was like all right he's not evil he's
not Hitler and he's certainly not a
homophobe I used to have these Trump
rallies on Sundays they didn't burn down
Rodeo Drive like black lives matter and
I'm telling you you could have walked in
that audience yes would a certain amount
of people have been like I [ __ ] Bill
Maher and but but you know what a lot of
people would have been there like you
know what Bill Maher's here that's
pretty cool think how different that
would be than if you went to an AOC
rally where you would be hated Beyond
imagination you're right it's just true
it's just they're they're the left or
more purists that was a seriously
important moment for me personally and
professionally meeting someone who I had
admired for you know 20 plus years I
wanted to be on Politically Incorrect
which I'm sure many of you younger
viewers of this show don't even know
what that was but it was his old show on
ABC years ago uh and I finally got to
meet him sit down with him you know
shoot the [ __ ] for a couple hours and
and do the dance and all that stuff and
he settled it I'll be on real time in
2023 I think I think in January we'll
see what happens
um and yeah I didn't get him where I
fully wanted to get him because he did
just days before these midterms
basically say you gotta vote for
Democrats but the important thing was
what we talked about at the end which is
if two guys like he and I who maybe were
like this and we've kind of gone this
way if we can't be within that accepted
parameter of difference where it's like
yeah so what we differ on some stuff but
we live in the same country and we love
this country and everything else then
then the country is really really in in
far more trouble than any of us would
like to admit so hopefully that was the
beginning of something not the end of
something and that very night despite
all the tequila that I drank and the
weed that I smoked on camera which I've
never done before and probably will
never do again I got on a red eye to go
go to New York to have a truly
incredible professional moment which is
that I went to NASDAQ as Rumble became a
public company and that is Chris
pavlovski who is the CEO of Rumble right
next to me and then my brother-in-law
southleb who is the CEO of locals and of
course locals and Rumble merged earlier
in the year and then of course you guys
all recognize Dan bongino who's a big
part of Rumble and we really are
building the parallel economy we are
building that that free internet that I
think there's so many pieces that are
heading right in our Direction in 2023
is going to look great on and as I said
to you guys I think the day I did the
live stream
from NASDAQ one of the coolest parts of
all of that was not just all the sweat
and and work that I put into building
the company and all the complexities of
merging and that we really were trying
to do something that everyone said
should be done but nobody was doing it
was that my face was on the freaking
Times Square digital billboard for hours
that afternoon basically three blocks
away from a corner where I used to stand
for about 60 or six nights a week two
hours a night handing out Comedy Club
tickets to make five bucks to do
stand-up and just a few blocks away 20
years later I had I had sold a company
that went public and it's like wow life
is a weird freaking thing uh in October
two big things happened we'll start with
Elon Musk finally buying Twitter which
has led us to so many of the other
things that we have been talking about
over the last couple weeks here he
tweeted out the bird is freed and then
of course the other thing bigger than
even Elon Musk behind Twitter uh Luke
was born two months to the day on
November 5th two months to the day that
Justin was born and Luke is doing
absolutely spectacular he didn't come
out right as smiley and ready to go into
this world as Justin did but he's
awesome now and he's great and they're
starting to recognize each other and it
is just fantastic and as I said before
I'm very very lucky and blessed and all
that good stuff November pretty pretty
good politically if you live here in the
great state of Florida because that
Rhonda Santos fellow won by 20 points
[Applause]
yeah
oh it's cold that was it that was it
that was it
15 points
50 I told the governor I told the
governor on June 2nd the Two of Us in
Orlando in the green room I said you're
gonna win by 15 points he laughed in my
face all right Governor DeSantis
that is awesome so the midterms didn't
quite turn out the way everyone sort of
thought they were going to turn out with
that crazy Red Wave but the Republicans
did get Congress back Florida is just
the absolute Apex of freedom in this
country and by extension the world right
now and I'm just thrilled and honored to
be a little piece of that as we continue
to build out all of the good stuff
that's happening here in Florida and and
really it's happening right here in
Florida and then finally in December in
this month well so many of the things
that I just went through they just
continued to build and the fight for
free speech online and the parallel
economy and all of that stuff so this
gives me a nice opportunity to tell you
guys that we are furthering our
partnership with Rumble I am obviously
part owner of Rumble but we are going to
be really expanding on our partnership
ship with Rumble going into 2023 we're
going to be expanding on our partnership
with locals and I'm going to sort of
leave it at that for the moment but when
we return to live shows on January 2nd
2023 we're going to have a slightly
extended format related to what we're
doing with locals and and more bonus
stuff and the extra live streams and a
whole bunch more uh and and really all
of that it's so connected to what we're
talking about all the time here there
are ways to communicate with you guys
that are not beholden to Big Tech that
are not beholden to all of the
censorious actors that are that are deep
within these big tech companies and
within our government and everything
else and we're on the Forefront in the
in the fight for Freedom so I'm I'm
thrilled that somehow this crazy idea
that I had to build this little tech
company a couple years ago has turned
into something really powerful so with
that in mind everybody I want to wish
you a very Merry Christmas a happy
Hanukkah a Happy New Year I hope you're
eating a lot and relaxing and enjoying
yourself take a little time off the
politics don't be crazy I hope you're
with some people you'll love and I look
forward to seeing you guys in 2023 as I
say at the end of every year this is
just the beginning and this one this one
really feels like it is on so many
fronts so I thank you for your support
and I'll see you next year